I once said if you want to liberate a
society all you need is the Internet I
was wrong I said those words back in
2011 when a Facebook page I anonymously
created helped spark the Egyptian
revolution the Arab Spring revealed
social medias greatest potential but it
also exposed its greatest shortcomings
the same tool that United us to topple
dictators eventually tore us apart I
would like to share my own experience in
using social media for activism and talk
about some of the challenges I have
personally faced and what could we do
about them in the early 2000s Arabs were
flooding the web thirsty for knowledge
for opportunities for connecting with
the rest of the people around the globe
we escaped our frustrating political
realities and lived a virtual
alternative life just like many of them
I was completely apolitical until 2009
at the time when I logged into social
media I started seeing more and more
Egyptians aspiring for a political
change in the country it felt like I was
not alone in June 2010 Internet changed
my life forever while browsing Facebook
I saw a photo a terrifying photo of a
tortured dead body of a young Egyptian
guy his name was hell it's ID Khaled was
29 year old Alexandrian who was killed
by police I saw myself in his picture I
thought I could be headed
I could not sleep that night and I
decided to do something i anonymously
created a Facebook page and called it we
are all Khaled Saeed in just three days
the page had over 100,000 people fellow
Egyptians who shared the same concern
whatever that is happening got to stop I
recruited my co admin Abdul Rahman
Monsour we worked together for hours and
hours we were crowd sourcing ideas from
the people were engaging them were
calling collectively for actions and
sharing news that the regime did not
want Egyptians to know the page became
the most followed page in the Arab world
it had more fans than established media
organizations and even top celebrities
On January 14th 2011 Banali fled out of
Tunisia after mounting protests against
his regime I saw a spark of hope
Egyptians on social media were wondering
if Tunisia did it why can't we
I posted an event on Facebook and called
it a revolution against corruption
injustice and dictatorship I posed a
question to the 300,000 users of the
page at the time today is 14th of
January 25th of January is the police
day it's a national holiday if a hundred
thousand of us take to the streets of
Cairo no one is going to stop us I
wonder if we could do it in just a few
days the invitation reached over a
million people and over a hundred
thousand people confirmed attendance
social media was crucial for this
campaign it helped a decentralized
movement arise it made people realize
that they were not alone and it made it
impossible for the regime to stop it at
the time they didn't even understand it
and on January 25th Egyptians flooded
the streets of Cairo and other cities
calling for change breaking the barrier
of fear and announcing a new era
then came the consequences a few hours
before the regime cut off the internet
and telecommunications I was walking in
a dark street in Cairo around midnight I
had just tweeted pray for Egypt the
government must be planning a massacre
tomorrow I was hit hard on my head I
lost my balance and fell down to find
four armed men surrounding me one
covered my mouth and the others
paralysed me I knew I was being
kidnapped by State Security I found
myself in a Cell handcuffed blindfolded
I was terrified so it was my family who
started looking for me in hospitals
police stations and even morgues after
my disappearance a few of my fellow
colleagues who knew I was the admin of
the page told the media about my
connection with that page and that I was
likely arrested by state security my
colleagues at Google started a search
campaign trying to find me and the
fellow protesters in the square demanded
my release after 11 days of complete
darkness I was set free and three days
later Mubarak was forced to step down
it was the most inspiring and empowering
moment of my life it was a time of great
hope
Egyptians lived a utopia for eighteen
days during the revolution they all
shared a belief that we could actually
live together despite our differences
that Egypt after Mubarak would be for
all but unfortunately the
post-revolution events were like a punch
in the gut the euphoria faded we failed
to build consensus and the political
struggle led to intense polarization
social media only amplified that state
by facilitating the
of misinformation rumors iike chambers
and hate speech the environment was
purely toxic my online world became a
battleground filled with trolls lies
hate speech I started to worry about the
safety of my family but of course this
wasn't just about me the polarization
reached its peak between the two main
powers the army supporters and the
Islamists people in the center like me
started feeling helpless
both groups wanted you to side with them
you were either with them or against
them and on 3rd of July 2013 the army
ousted Egypt first democratically
elected president after three days of
popular protests that demanded his
resignation that day I made a very hard
decision I decided to go silent
completely silent it was a moment of
defeat I stayed silent for more than two
years and I used the time to reflect on
everything that happened trying to
understand why did it happen it became
clear to me that while it's true that
polarization is primarily driven by our
human behavior social media shapes this
behavior and magnifies its impact say
you want to say something that is not
based on a fact pick a fight or ignore
someone that you don't like this is all
natural human impulses but because of
Technology acting on these impulses is
only one click away in my view there are
five critical challenges facing today's
social media first we don't know how to
deal with rumors rumors that confirm
people biases are now believed and
spread among millions of people second
we create our own equal chambers we tend
to only communicate with people that we
agree with and thanks to social media we
have mute
unfollow and block everybody else
third online discussions quickly descend
into angry mobs all of us probably know
that it's as if we forget that the
people behind screens are actually real
people and not just avatars and forth it
became really hard to change our
opinions because of the speed and
privity of social media we are forced to
jump into conclusions and write sharp
opinions in hundred forty characters
about complex world affairs and once we
do that it lives forever on the internet
and we are less motivated to change
these views even when new evidence arise
fifth and in my point of view this is
the most critical today
our social media experiences are
designed in a way that favors
broadcasting over engagements posts over
discussions shallow comments over deep
conversations it's as if we agreed that
we are here to talk at each other
instead of talking with each other I
witnessed how these critical challenges
contributed to an already polarized
Egyptian society but this is not just
about Egypt polarization is going on the
rise in the whole world we need to work
hard on figuring out how technology
could be part of the solution rather
than part of the problem there's a lot
of debate today on how to combat online
harassment and fight trolls this is so
important
no one could argue against that but we
need to also think about how to design
social media experiences that promote
civility and reward thoughtfulness I
know for a fact if I write a post that
is more sensational more one-sided
sometimes andrey and aggressive i get to
have more people see that post i will
get more attention but what if we put
more focus on quality what is more
important the total number of readers of
opposed to right
or who are the people who have impact
that read what you write
couldn't we just give people more
incentives to engage in conversations
rather than just broadcasting opinions
all the time or reward people for
reading and responding to views that
they disagree with and also make it
socially acceptable that we change our
minds or probably even reward that what
if we have a matrix that say how many
people change their mind and that
becomes part of this our social media
experience if I could track how many
people are changing their minds
I'd probably write more thoughtfully
trying to do that rather than appealing
to the people who already agree with me
and liking because I just confirmed
their biases we also need to think about
effective crowd sourcing mechanisms to
fact-check widely spread online
information and reward people who take
part of that in essence we need to
rethink today's social media ecosystem
and redesign its experiences to reward
thoughtfulness civility and mutual
understanding as a believer in the
Internet I teamed up with a few friends
started a new project trying to find
answers and explore possibilities our
first product is a new media platform
for conversations we're hosting
conversations that promote mutual
understanding and hopefully change minds
we don't claim to have the answers but
we started experimenting with different
discussions about very divisive issues
such as race gun control the refugee
debate relationship between Islam and
terrorism these are conversations that
matter
today at least one out of three people
on the planet have access to the
Internet but part of this Internet is
being held captive by the list noble
aspects of our human behavior five years
ago I said if you want to liberate the
society all you need is the Internet
today I believe
if we want to liberate the society we
first need to liberate the Internet
thank you very much